[Musique]
l'autre c'est à ce soir jean martin
aussant et jean luc landry bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir on va parler de dette
de déficit de pib dans un instant mais
je vais vous entendre sur l'e-mail je
rappelle qu'il ya une entente de
principe qui a été conclue finalement et
qui était surtout accepté par le
syndicat le syndicat a accepté à 78% la
dernière entente de principe qui a été
conclu entre le syndicat et l'employeur
donc les travailleurs qui ont accepté
cette entente jean luc hess que comment
se fait-il qu'on en soit leurs quatre
mois plus tard 180000 ports qui sont en
attente une négociation âpre difficile
est ce que le gouvernement a trop
attendu qu'est ce que vous en pensez
un environnement avait pas intervenir là
dedans il fallait que le processus suit
son cours il ça fonctionnait vous
trouvez que quatre mois c'est long mais
il ya 500 emplois qui sont souvent les
travailleurs en grosse augmentation
de rémunération totale
étalé sur plusieurs années
26 5% dont 10% à fournir mais oui c'est
quand même bon sens en tout cas aucun
gros rattrapage
et là mes employés là donc pour répondre
à votre question
est intervenu pour aider le processus
mais il fallait attendre que les gens
soient prêts à négocier et il sera prêt
ben moi je pense que ça aurait pu être
une catastrophe de long terme de
gaspillage alimentaire mais que je suis
tombé de ma chaise quand j'ai lu la
statistique un parent mature pour être à
l'origine de 56 cents repas donc
imaginer 180000 parfois 5 à 6 ans donc
c'est ce genre de gaspillage leur était
absolument
horrible il d'ailleurs on sait toujours
pas comment on va écouler l'espèce de
boulot qu'il a tout cela ce sera réglé
non plus et je pense que c'est peut-être
une bonne occasion de revoir ce qu'on
appelle un service essentiel et là je
vais pas dire que c'est comme la police
ou les pompiers ou les ambulanciers mais
quand on parle de sécurité alimentaire
de transformation alimentaire ou même du
secteur agricole en général je pense que
c'est à la base de toute vie c'est
logique et peut-être que le gouvernement
aurait pu intervenir plus tôt
le gouvernement aurait pu intervenir un
peu plus tôt pour régler ça jean-luc ce
sens vous voulez intervenir
la sécurité alimentaire on mangera -2
pas on va manger peut être autre chose
là deuxièmement c'est une usine à
travers le canada ya aucune excuse moi
comartin millions aucune justification
pour intervenir l'attend au nom de la
sécurité alimentaire je crois
aussi plus le gouvernement intervient
plus les gens s'habituent à ce que le
gouvernement intervienne et plus ils
vont demander au gouvernement
d'intervenir ça sera long terme sa
solution n'aurait pas le problème on a
un système qui fonctionne et c'est des
bonnes nouvelles il y en a des
négociations politiques sont là on n'est
plus dans les années soixante dix où ils
vendent et des guerres d'un arriver des
choses car été complètement débile comme
ça vous étiez ok je vous amène sur la
dette et le déficit si vous le voulez
bien on va aller tout de suite à la
dette et le déficit et renault tourne
aujourd'hui qui a dit qu'il ne voit à
répéter en fait qu'ils voient les
déficits 0 en moins de dix ans mais sans
nécessairement des coupes budgétaires ou
va-t-il coupé il a dit on va stimuler
l'économie sans faire des coupes
budgétaires jean martin est ce que vous
croyez à ça est ce que c'est possible
mais c'est possible de réduire le
déficit et même la dette fédérale sur
le canada avec un ratio dette sur pib de
plus de 60% il ne réduit à femmes pour
ça en l'espace de dix ans mais oublions
pas comment ça c'est fait ça se fait
encore autant mettant pendant la
procession de la caisse
d'assurance-emploi et en pelletant
beaucoup du fardeau aux provinces donc
ya pas de recette magique il faut se
regrouper les services ou à augmenter
les revenus et si on mise sur une
croissance économique saine simple
simplement la croissance économique pour
résorber tout ça ça va prendre toute une
croissance mieux que la chine pendant
dix ans donc je pense qu'il va y avoir
coupé le cialis nécessairement si on
veut aller vite maintenant le fait de
réserver cette bête là non je dis petit
je
sais puisque les les camps selon nos
informations en ce moment on est dans
une des caves du jury de main d'oeuvre
et il part de stimuler la demande
d'emploi
qui va se réveiller quelque part
alors monsieur autour d'une question de
sémantique jus d'accord ils ont marqué
c'est très possible de revenir un
dc10 dans les prochains et 10 ans mais
là la sémantique c'est contrôler les
dépenses qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut pas dire que vous devez les pc mais
si en termes réels elles bail évidemment
c'est des contrôles qui sont sévères
sont modiques c'est possible oui oui
mais en ce moment la personne qui est
entré il n'est pas reparti en ce moment
qui est dans cette direction l'orgueil
dans la sémantique jean luc et jean
martin ya également monsieur autour qui
dit qu'on va sous les libéraux dans les
quatre prochaines années tripler la
dette d'ici à 2025 jusqu'à 1800
milliards de dollars en admettant qu'on
aura le même niveau de progression des
dépenses mais en oubliant que les
dépenses vont baisser quand même pas mal
cette année est-ce que ça est ce que ça
tient la route ou est-ce qu'on est que
dans la sémantique politique est ce
qu'on parle des vrais chiffres en ce
moment quand on parle de dette et de
déficit global est
en période électorale surtout quand un
parti parle des chiffres de notre parti
il pas le meilleur angle en fait pour
les illustrer et c'est sûr que si les
dépenses sont moins grandes que l'an
dernier parce que ça a été un record de
milliers de milliards distribués à
gauche et à droite l'économie va aussi
aller mieux que l'an dernier où il ya eu
un recul quand même assez sévère sur un
trimestre ou deux donc ces chiffres
lagon s'ajuster de même l adepte du
canada moi j'ai évidemment que les
finances publiques c'est éminemment
collectif et il faut il voir il faut
enfin gouvernement a une responsabilité
de base de bien gérer le budget mais
n'oublions pas que le canada est encore
parmi les pays du g7 le mieux le mieux
placé la meilleure santé financière
publique et l'allemagne avant la
pandémie avait à peu près le taux
d'endettement du canada actuellement
après la première année de pandémie des
états unis étaient le double du niveau
du canada actuellement avant la pandémie
donc quand on se compare on se console
un peu quand même mais vous trouvez pas
que ça manque de chiffres un peu petite
projection et et de cadre budgétaire et
de cadres de financiers
l'udc oui on devrait demander à chacun
deux chiffres y est de faire des
estimations d'ailleurs j'atteins le
directeur du budget normalement on
devrait avoir un apport qui va
incorporer toutes les promesses la dapa
rejet du budget fédéral et qui va nous
dire combien ça va coûter je vous dis
qu'il ya des gens qui vont être pas mal
surpris je crois qu'à absolument et jean
pierre aubry nous a préparé un tableau
pour nous rappeler en fait que la hausse
de l'endettement par rapport au pib
passe de 31 à 50 % dans les prochaines
années mais on oublie le plan de relance
le plan de relance de 108 milliards de
madame free ne nous amène à 56,58 pour
ça mais ça c'est pas encore incorporé
est ce que les libéraux ne devrait pas
être responsable en nous donnant est
exactement la teneur de la dette
prochaine jean martin en tenant compte
justement de ce plan de relance qu'ils
veulent mettre en place mais encore une
fois c'est le propre de tous les partis
en campagne électorale ils sont un peu
sélectif dans les chiffres et les
statistiques qui veulent bien l'utiliser
quand ils nous présentent leur plein
mais effectivement si on inclut toutes
les dépenses premier qu'on fait
certaines hypothèses de continuité dans
certaines dépassent ce qui sera pas le
coq comme vous le disiez la csu qui
aurait pas autant de milliers de
milliards de distribuer jusqu'en 2020
moment donné est d'ailleurs moi ce qui
me fait peur c'est le jour où ça va
arrêter jour où l'état va arrêter
d'aider les entreprises et les
particuliers qui se sentent plus riches
qu'avant la pandémie pratiquement j'ai
hâte de voir les vrais impacte les vrais
effets de la pandémie sur l'économie
rend doublement genre le cantona
moi je crois qu est l économie va créer
les conditions fiscales et monétaires
sont les plus expansionniste que j'ai
vue dans ma vie et
jusqu'ici rejeté à peu près 7 8
récession n'est pas prise c'est une
reprise forte et qui va continuer et on
n'a pas joint leurs stimuli plus on a un
creux un peu en été on l'a vu dans le
pib ni statistique canada aujourd'hui
mais quand même quand on regarde la
reprise par rapport aux autres cessions
du passé on remonte plus rapidement que
tu en 2008 ou en 91 ou même en 82
jean martin je les ai un des secteurs a
fait qu'il va aider l'économie assure le
but les secteurs des services surtout
pour les économies avancées comme le
canada ou au québec c'est le secteur qui
tarde encore le plus à se relever puis
quand ça s'arrête à plein régime là on
va vraiment avoir une belle recrue jean
luc
de jean-martin 1000 points exactement le
point important c'est que pourquoi il ya
un psy on dit que la sarre mon pull pour
le dernier trois quatre mois c'est parce
que c'est la reprise de l'emploi dans
les emplois de proximité et ont été
extrêmement prudent dans la colline et
deuxième point important au canada les
statistiques trimestrielles
et ça c'est que promesses réelles
fluctuent énormément y'a pas un
trimestre au canada c'est qu'on tendance
ok on est averti jean-luc merci jean
martin aussi
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit